hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmccontrolac.l2-3.1.3 control the flow
of cui in accordance with approved
authorizations
[Music]
say hey if you're a defense contract
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone try to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist sp80171 compliant stuff
on top of an already colossal workload
well I've got great news you found your
home here at on-call compliance
Solutions where we can help you
transform into your company's on-call
compliance Hero Let's get into it so
this is a very important control when it
comes to cmmc level 2. this control is
all about having some sort of a policy
in place which dictates who what systems
and how cui can flow or be stored
processed or transmitted that's what the
law says so why is it so important
because without an actual policy like a
written policy this is not like active
or like a group policy or anything like
that it's an actual written policy okay
or guiding document in place it is too
easy for even small organizations to
accidentally allow access to cui by
unauthorized users again how do your
people really know where it's okay to
you know ncui or how to send cui the
easiest way and again the way that
compliance mandates you do it you
basically have to have something that I
call the cui flow control policy okay
it's a written policy that tells your
organization hey this is where it's
allowed to go creating a nasty security
problem okay if you don't have one right
so that's the whole point is if you
don't have one of these flow control
policies you got a really nasty security
problem because no one really knows it's
not in writing you can't refer back to
it how they're supposed to transmit data
process data store data that kind of
thing now the idea with CMC control
ac.l2-3.1.3 dot dot dot
now I gotta tell you it always helps if
when I prepare the slides they're
actually there but in this case they're
blank so if you see me looking down it's
because I'm not looking at the
teleprompter all right so hey uh back on
this control control three right
ac.l2-3.1.3 here are the assessment
points okay number one they're going to
look at determine if information flow
control policies are actually defined
okay so right here in this moment
they're basically saying hey look I want
to see a definition of how cui is
supposed to be flowing that should
trigger to you written policy all right
if we were giving a sample answer I
would say the organization has a cui
flow control policy in place authorized
users are trained on this policy right
that's important only authorized users
are given access to cui with written
requirements right the policy to follow
the cui flow control policy that's how
you're going to determine if if it's
controlled and in a policy all right now
uh assessment Point number two
determinive methods and enforcement
mechanisms are controlling the flow of
cui as defined or are defined methods
and enforcement are defined via active
directory right maybe we've got some
group policy in there but most
importantly the cui flow control policy
and then maybe we throw in a little risk
management sop because of course you're
going to be doing some risk management
on how your cui is Flowing to make sure
that you're essentially you know you've
considered what the risks are of how the
cui is Flowing all that stuff's really
important now Point number three
determine if designated networks excuse
me determinive designated sources and
destinations I.E networks individuals
and devices for cui within systems and
between interconnected systems are
identified again if I was going to give
you a sample answer that I'd say hey
look networks individuals and devices
handling cui are all identified okay
they're identified via Network
documentation right you got all that
documentation Network Maps Etc uh cui
flow control and then maybe we're also
calling out active directory because
that's what's going to identify who the
people are and you know tie them to what
they're doing
um
determining if authorizations for
controlling the by the way another
example that might be in there is your
physical premise access system right
like your door fob system that way for
physical cui which is also something to
be considered uh maybe not in that last
example but physical cui has to be
accounted for too so how are the people
flowing in and out of the building do
you have accountability they're in the
building do you know who touched the cui
do we have video cameras up on the wall
all those things could be potential
answers uh Point number four final point
is it four five five yeah there's five
points you're looking for on this one
determine if approved authorizations for
controlling the flow of cui are actually
enforced now we got to actually prove
that we're following the policy and that
this stuff is actually enforced so again
we would probably demonstrate during a
cmfc uh certification review or
assessment we'd probably be showing them
active directory some group policy stuff
uh system access and file system
permissions right who's actually got
access maybe we demonstrate that XYZ
user can't get into a folder that has
cui their permissions denied uh and uh
our uh systems are all in place and to
enforce approved authorizations and cui
access so again those are some really
really great examples of exactly how we
would do this now you're going to see
this really cool cut in the video in one
second because the internet's magic so
hey and on call we work with defense
contractors just like you who've had
this D fars nist itar and cmmc
compliance stuff dropped in their laps
like a poorly written script by myself
we teach you how to level up and be a
proper on-call compliance hero for your
company eliminating gaps gray areas and
shooting some of the most ghetto video
on the internet
and all that other good stuff so if
you're looking for more help getting
compliant our compliance experts are
always on call for you visit cmfcc
complianceecrets.com or check out the
Bible below for links to get help right
now and if you love the content we're
putting out here for you because I
really like clearly I'm trying so hard
all right help us out with a big thumbs
up on that like button or write
something really funny in the comments
because doing these videos is well it's
for you guys and we love you and defense
contractors are who we eat sleep leave
and breath live
and breathe for yeah anyway well we're
all about it hey you know what until the
next compliance tip my friends stay safe
and secure out there and hit us in the
comments below if you'd like me to make
even worse gaps on the next video I'll
see you on the next one
foreign
[Music]